hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason io
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
among the five intellectual virtues or
that is good dispositions of the
the intellectual or rational part of our
soul that aristotle discusses in nico
mccann ethics book six we find
wisdom which is a translation of the
greek word sophia this is a term that
was used quite a lot before aristotle uh
sometimes uh more or less synonymously
with the term that we're translating as
practical wisdom or prudence that is
pronasis
aristotle wants to treat it as something
quite separate
from prudence as we'll talk about in in
just a bit
um he thinks that this is actually in
many respects the highest of all of the
intellectual virtues that is the highest
state or capacity that we can bring the
human soul or our mind to
and he notes uh when he's first talking
about it that it's used in a very broad
sense
that he wants to to try to
mention
in part so he can get away from he talks
about
people being declared as being sophos or
wise
when they are masters of their fields
fields there is translating techne and
aristotle is using that in the i
understand the pun here technical sense
of art or crap so for example um the
sophists the people who wandered around
greece uh several generations before
aristotle and then continuing out into
aristotle's own day
who would claim to be able to teach all
sorts of things they were they were
presenting themselves as being wise some
of them would say look i only teach
rhetoric like origius did and gorgeous
was considered to be a wise man because
he had mastered the art the technique of
rhetoric other people might be
considered wise in such a sense because
they are great statesmen like pericles
or
particularly good doctors
we don't really know if eric simakis was
a great doctor or not but let's just say
for a point of reference that he was
then he might be considered wise in that
sense
aerosol also says you know sometimes we
say this about people who are not
masters of any one particular field but
seem to have a wide
range
of skills and knowledge as well not just
the jack of all trades
who can't really do much effectively is
mediocre in a whole bunch of areas but
who's who's good in a bunch of areas and
arsenal says this gets us on the right
track
because
what wisdom is really about is
possessing what we might call
comprehensive
knowledge or understanding
but it's not going to be of everything
interestingly aristotle is going to take
human affairs for example and say the
wise person is not particularly
concerned with with those and we'll talk
about that in just a moment
he does say that in in a strict sense
that he wants to talk about it
it is the most exact the uh crib
of
yeah of sciences or knowledges of the
piston
um this is an important term aristotle
used this at the beginning of the ethics
if you remember in in book one to say
that ethics is not an accremos
an exact
precise science in the way that say
mathematics is
and we should expect you know a little
bit more loosey-goosey-ness to ethics
than we do in mathematics in part
because ethics has to do with human
affairs which have a lot of variance
within them we have to go to the level
of the particulars where things often
get quite quite messy and murky
wisdom
is not going to have that sort of
impediment in part because it's not
going to have to do so much with human
affairs it's going to have to do instead
with things that are higher or things
that are more
basic
so what is wisdom consistent
aristotle is actually going to define
wisdom in terms of two other
intellectual virtues
knowledge or scientific knowledge
episteme
we've done a video about that that you
can check out and what we translate
difficultly is intellect intelligence
uh intuition sometimes that's translated
as mind
noose noose in greek
and aristotle says
that
wisdom actually encompasses and
integrates both of these so that a wise
person is going to
by
virtue of being wise
possess knowledge and possess this other
intellectual virtue of intellect or
intelligence
why
well because wisdom
it knows not only
the conclusions and presumably also the
reasoning processes the logismoy
for uh that comprise knowledge which
work from first principles which
knowledge doesn't actually itself
possess
but accepts from elsewhere and takes on
words accept them from intellect
intellect supplies the first principles
to to knowledge and then somebody who's
within the field you know reading a
textbook sitting in a class can just be
given the first principles kind of
accept them
provisionally or maybe the rest of their
life and work with the knowledge that
they have without fully understanding
where all of these original
starting points came from the person who
has wisdom does understand that they
have a true conception they they grasp
the truth as aristotle says there of
these first principles that are being
supplied by this other
virtue or this other habit
better yet disposition within the mind
of intellect or intelligence so it fuses
these two together and the person who is
wise is going to
not only know where to start from but
where to go from from there
aristotle says that it is distinct from
prudence this is the point that we've
brought up several times he also
considers whether it's also distinct
from political science cape political
episteme
which is going to be rolled uh under
prudence uh in aristotle's treatment in
nickel mccann ethics book six and he
says that it's not those things so it's
quite possible for a person to be
wise thalis is a great example he was a
malaysian philosopher made fun of
by a servant woman because as he was
looking at the heavens uh one night he
fell into a ditch and she was like ah
look at this you know dummy uh he
doesn't really know how to take care of
himself
thoughtless actually got the last laugh
on them because through his
meteorological observations he figured
out his according to stories that there
was going to be a really great olive
crop bought up all of the olive presses
beforehand and then charged people an
arm and a leg in order to use them to
press their their bumper crop of olives
and then people quit saying that he
lacked prudence but wisdom and prudence
are two different things for aristotle
why can't wisdom also encompass prudence
because wisdom has to do with that
highest part of the rational part of the
soul that only deals with things that
only contemplates things that
have first principles that are
unchanging that are by necessity that we
can say things about universally that we
can possess
knowledge about
prudence
and also you know uh political science
uh uh techne all those sorts of things
those have to do with the shapes the the
shifting shapes of the realm of human
affairs
in which there's a lot of
and so wisdom doesn't you might say go
down that far it doesn't deal with the
particulars in that sense
instead what does it occupy itself with
well aristotle talks about it having to
do with things that are most worthy
by nature the word that he uses there is
uh
those things which are most worthy of
being honored so
for aristotle and for the ancient greeks
this was um the heavens you know they
they were particularly interested in
that um you could say that aristotle's
metaphysics
dealing with being qua being
which also does deal with the heavens to
some some degree um would would be
similarly uh you know exalted like that
human affairs not so much aristotle says
human beings are not the best thing in
the universe i suppose if we were to to
change our views on these uh our
starting points you know start from a
different uh noose a different
origin point of of reasoning maybe we
would say that wisdom actually does have
to do with with human beings
if we think that human beings are indeed
the highest thing that there is
other people might contest that but in
any case aristotle thinks that wisdom
the person who actually possesses this
this habitual disposition within their
mind of wisdom is going to be spending a
lot of time contemplating the greatest
things
um he talks in terms of you know people
like phthalates uh is you know being
said to have knowledge that is
rare that is marvelous that people you
know uh are in or at
being difficult and being semi-divine
daimony's um
um
and this sort of characterizes what we
think of somebody who who genuinely has
wisdom this is a rather different
conception
i think that we have today
because we would often associate because
of our way in which we do things
what we understand to be
wisdom
with either the political or economic or
something like that or with production
or
perhaps we associate it with the the
scientists who who might actually
possess
you know
knowledge in arizona's sense but might
be lacking in in the first principles uh
many of them it's quite often that you
can find people who have scientific
knowledge but can't really tell you
where the first principles come from
because that's not something that falls
within scientific knowledge is uh
curview where the the principles come
from just knows these are the principles
for our our science the person who's
wise really has
a
grasp on all of this
so that is the
virtue the intellectual virtue of wisdom
in aristotle's nick of mccain ethics
book six